[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
too
[Music]
so
hello the sample family uh my name is
don jacobs
and i'm one of the members here at the
table
and it is my pleasure to welcome you i'm
so
thankful that you are here and that you
get to join us whether it's live
whether you're watching at a different
time and be able to participate at that
that way uh we just want you to know
that you are
loved and welcome here so it doesn't
matter if you're
white brown uh black yellow
or some other kin skin color you're
welcomed
and you were loved here if you're male
female or somewhere in between
um straight or some version of queer
you're made in the image of god and that
you are welcomed here
and it doesn't matter if you're a sinner
or a saint
if you choose to vote democrat
republican libertarian
or some other political affiliation we
love you the same
and you are welcome here so this is the
place for you
i do have a couple of announcements that
i want to go over
with you all is that there is a
the table book club is
announcing an august book selection the
title of the book
is the other west moore one name two
fates by westmore
um so it's going to begin saturday
august the 29th at 10 10 a.m to discuss
uh the book club is actually um led by
sarah johns and glenda baron
and it meets monthly these are two
amazing wonderful people um and it would
be
a shame to miss out so if you enjoy your
reading
or just want to get connected so this is
a good group for you
and if you want more information just
email sarah
her email is going to be sarah at the
table
tx.org the other announcement
that i have for you is that because of
the kind of
pandemic this meeting is a little
delayed but basically we'll be having
our second state of the table meeting
online on in a couple saturday sundays
it's going to be sunday august the 23rd
it's going to follow shortly after the
service and this is again a chance for
just
for you guys to get the inside scoop on
the table so anything from finances
to the mission division and just the
kind of the scope for the rest of the
year
so i just have one quick prayer that i
want to share with you all
before we get started so if you want
mine bow your heads and pray with me
um laura just thank you so much for
all that you have are doing in our lives
um thank you so much for this
opportunity to come together
to worship you to open our hearts and
minds to
where you want us to be i pray
for this time that wherever we are that
we will just quiet our voices why all
the different things are going on in our
lives
um quiet some of the noises the
distractions
um and everything like that and help us
just to focus
on what you have for us at this moment
and in this time
be with everyone who is sharing tonight
through
music or messaging and i pray that
we will hear your voice in christ i pray
amen
hey everybody i hope you're having a
good week
say hi joe hi uh we're gonna play some
songs together
uh so sit back and sing with us um
just take uh take a break from the week
before it gets started
or if you're looking at sunday as the
end of your week
uh just take take this hour and just
relax and hang out with us
[Music]
you surround me with
a song
of deliverance
from my enemies
[Music]
i am a child
of god
you have chosen me
i've been born again
to your family
[Music]
fear
am a child
i'm no longer
[Music]
i am a child
of god i
am a child of god
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
right through it's just
[Applause]
[Music]
i am a child of god
yes i am
a child of god
keep fighting voices in my mind
say i'm not enough
every single lie that tells me
i will never measure
[Music]
everybody
me once again just who i am
[Music]
you say i am
you say i am yours
and i believe
what you say for
[Music]
matters me is everything you think
i can't feel the things
[Music]
when i don't belong
you say i am yours
[Applause]
and i believe
oh i believe what you say of me
you have every failure got
you have every victory
[Music]
we
you say
[Music]
you say i am hell
when i am falling short
and when i don't belong
you say i am yours
and i believe
oh i believe what you
say of me oh
i believe yes i believe
i believe what you
say of me yes i
[Music]
believe
thanks josh and jill that was so great
um
we're gonna sing good good father and uh
if this is a song that you're not
familiar with it kind of
um puts god in the role of father
in the song and for some of us that can
be a tricky
thing um for one reason or another
whether it's
maybe a difficult relationship with your
own father or maybe just difficult to
have god personified in the role of
man when he is so much more and
and um so far beyond just what this
human experience is
um but i just wanted to encourage you
guys for me what's been helpful
um as i've
journeyed uh through different times in
my faith where i've had questions or
where i've struggled
um to understand god and who he is
is just to think if he were if he were a
person
if we tried to boil him down which he's
so much more than that thank goodness
but if we did
he would be the best one if he were a
father
he would be the best father
he would be a full source of love
and acceptance and encouragement and
beauty
and clarity um so i just want to
encourage you guys
as we go into the song
whatever your view of god is and
wherever you find yourself in
relationship to him
i hope that you see him as the best
version
because that's who i believe he is
that's who he has been for me
um wherever i find him
he's always been good so
[Music]
i've heard
a thousand stories
[Music]
you're a good father
it's who you are it's who you
are it's who you
[Music]
i are it's who i am
i've seen many
searching for answers
[Music]
it's who you are it's who you
are it's who you
[Music]
good are it's who you are
it's who you are it's who you are it's
who i
am it's who i am
[Music]
you are perfect in all of your ways
love so undeniable
i can hardly speak
peaceful unexplainable lie
i can hardly think as you call me
deeper still
[Music]
deeper still into love
love
won't you calm me deeper still
into love love
love won't you call me
deeper still won't you call me
[Music]
love
good good father it's who you
are it's who you are
it's who you are and i'm
loved by you it's who i am
it's who i am it's who i
am you're a good good father
it's who you are it's who you are
it's who you are and i'm loved by you
it's who i am it's who i am
it's who i am
[Music]
god i'm so grateful that you are
more than even what we can understand
or explain or comprehend
that you are the more the better
you are love personified in jesus
[Music]
thank you for being the best
that we could imagine
[Music]
holy pure and accepting
and forgiving and redeeming
god i pray that in whatever way we
experience you
it would be the best way
[Music]
it would be the thing that connects us
back to who we are
and who we were made to be
the thing that connects us back to love
[Music]
thank you for this community god thank
you for the relationships inside of it
and i pray that we would experience you
more and more inside of it amen
amen thank you maggie and mindy and josh
and joe
and don just for being apart tonight
so uh grace and peace it's good to be
with you all my name is brett
and i just want to welcome you to the
table and our
our vision here is really of a of a
community of people who
are learning to shift from
a reactionary fear-based
kind of ego based way of living and
we're trying to shift
out of that towards the way of christ
the way of love the way of calm the way
that
that really enables us to see god
ourselves and others with clarity
uh that's really what we're all about
here and so we
are right now we're in a series titled
luke and
uh we are gonna um
kind of uh really just kind of walking
our way through we're taking a few
chapters a week and just kind of picking
something out and kind of walking
through it so
kind of what we've named in previous
weeks is that the the book of luke is
kind of like
a a literary or um
kind of a written documentary you can
think of it in that way almost like a
film
uh except of course in book form and
it's really just this
kind of weaving together of accounts and
stories about the life of
and teachings of jesus and so
today we come to to really one of this
gospels
i mean arguably its most famous story uh
or right there at the top uh it's one
that has been
really endlessly read and re-read
interpreted reinterpreted it's a story
that has resonated with
millions of people uh and i think it's
because in many ways it's our story you
know we we
see ourselves in these characters we all
know what it is to squander our gifts
and our life horribly
we know what it is to regret our choices
to um to run from the very people
who love us well we've all found
ourselves
in that place where our heart aches
and we long to go home
home really to ourselves home to our
families sometimes
and even kind of in a spiritual sense
home to god and
so this of course is known uh commonly
as the story of the prodigal or the
wayward son
though i prefer to call it the story of
the two
uh prodigal sons because we often forget
the second one and so the title of my
message tonight
is lost at home
and so we're going to begin with our
reading this is going to be from luke
chapter 15 verses 11 through 32
where jesus really just tells the story
so the text says jesus continued
there was a man who had two sons
the younger one said to his father
father
give me my share of the estate
so he being the father divided his
property
between them and not long after that the
younger son got together all he had
and he set off for a distant country and
there
squandered his wealth in wild living
after he had spent everything there was
a severe famine
in that whole country and he began to be
in need so he went and hired himself out
to a citizen of that country
who sent him to the fields to feed pigs
remember this is a jewish setting so
this is kind of the lowest of the low
for this young jewish man
verse 16 he longed to fill his stomach
with the pods that the pigs were eating
but no one gave him anything
when he came to his senses he said how
many of my father's hired
servants have food despair and here i
am starving to death i will set out
and i'll go back to my father and say to
him father i have sinned against heaven
and against you
i am no longer worthy to be called your
son make me like one of your hired
servants
so he got up and went to his father
but while he was still a long way
off his father saw him and was filled
with compassion
for him he ran to his son threw his arms
around him and kissed him
the son said to him father i've sinned
against heaven
and against you i'm no longer worthy to
be called your son
but the father said to his servants
quick bring the best robe
and put it on him put a ring on his
finger and sandals on his feet
bring the fattened calf and kill it
let's have a feast
and celebrate for this son of mine
was dead and is alive again
he was lost and is found so they began
to celebrate and meanwhile
the older son was in the field when he
came near the house
he heard music and dancing so he
called one of the servants and asked him
what's going on your brother has come
he replied and your father has killed
the fattened calf because he has him
back safe and sound
the older brother became angry
and refused to go in so his father
went out and pleaded with him but he
answered his father look
all these years i've been slaving for
you
i've never disobeyed your orders yet you
never
gave me even a young goat so i could
celebrate with my friends
but when this son of yours who has
squandered your property with
prostitutes comes home
you kill the fattened calf for him my
son the father said
you're always with me everything i have
is yours
but we had to celebrate and be glad
because this brother of yours was
dead and is alive again he was lost
and is found
so here's the key question for tonight
why do you think jesus includes the
second half of the story
i mean if you think about it it could
have ended right at verse 24.
for this son of mine was dead and is
alive again
he was lost but has been found and they
began to celebrate
end of story and it would be happy happy
story
so i'm kind of thinking like why the the
twist
of part two so i think there's um
there's a historical reason
for this the historical reason is
because of jesus's audience
now here are the opening verses of
chapter 15. i didn't read this um at the
very beginning
so this is the literally verse starting
in verse 1. now the tax collectors and
sinners
were all gathering around to hear jesus
but the pharisees and the teachers of
the law
muttered this man welcomes
sinners and eats with them
then verse 3 then jesus told them this
parable and so jesus he goes on to tell
them
three stories about lostness and
foundness
and the grace of god and the high point
of the chapter
is this third story the one we just read
about these two sons
so to answer the question why not just
end with and they began to celebrate
and the answer is because jesus um was
not only speaking to the tax collectors
and the sinners these would have been
people um you know basically represented
by the younger wayward
son um the rebellious one so to speak
um who throughout this message i'll call
son number one
jesus was also speaking to longtime
religious folks you know leaders pillars
of the community and specifically of the
religious community
um who throughout this message i'll call
son number two
so so that's the historical biblical
reason uh but
but the reason i think it matters for us
tonight
is that most of us spend the majority of
our lives
as sun slash daughter number two
like on the one hand yes we know what it
is to be the first prodigal you know to
spend
our youth in stupidity um but
normally not always but normally
you know our prefrontal cortex finishes
developing
and by our mid to late 20s we're like
okay
i've i've i've got to get my life
together it's kind of been the story
where he says
and the man uh the son came to his
senses you know and that's kind of us
like eventually we kind of come to our
senses
and and what do we do we start making
better decisions you know we go back to
school
or we throw ourselves into our careers
or we you know maybe begin raising
children
or we volunteer at non-profits and you
know try to give
back and we perhaps you you know start
attending church
and we're we're just kind of doing you
know the things we're supposed to
do but you get a few years down that
road
and perhaps it's not
quite all it's cracked up to be
like we thought that by getting our
lives together
all our problems would be solved that
um that that this loneliness
this ache this lack of peace this kind
of
gnawing sense of not enoughness
we thought that would go away or at
least subside
you know once we all became respectable
children in the family you know getting
our stuff together
but but it but perhaps it hasn't
really been the case in fact
child number two son or daughter number
two now
has the pressures and responsibilities
and a mortgage and suddenly the economy
is terrible and we're all stuck at home
because of covid and meanwhile sibling
number one
is that they're just partying up in
florida
a little bitterness escaping from my
uh they those they need to learn some
responsibility
right and like this is um
i i think this is this is why i think we
should connect with
son daughter number two and yet i
do kind of imagine that this
this older son now he he might have had
one thing going for him
like one happy thought that kept him
going through the tough times
that and this was it at least by staying
on the straight and narrow he was
earning his father's affection
he was earning his keep at least with
every passing day
his position with the father was
stronger while that of the younger son
was weaker in fact you might even say
that that knowledge motivated him
to push harder to try harder like a
long-distance runner who pushes the pace
precisely because she senses the
weakness and fatigue in her rivals
i'm imagining the older son is deriving
a sense of self a sense of worth
from his superior faithfulness and
obedience he is outpacing his younger
brother i mean you can hear it
in verse 29 can't you this is the quote
i've never
disobeyed your orders can you hear it i
mean he's effectively saying
i've always done the right thing i have
stayed on the straight and narrow path
i i am giving it my best but when
this son of yours comes home
you you just act like he hung the moon
how could you do this to me
how could you betray me
like this what kind of a family is this
how do you expect to run a family where
the more respectable people
are disrespected
in these kinds of ways how can you
reward stupidity
i don't even know who you are anymore
heck i
i don't even know who i am anymore i
mean i used to be the good one
uh but apparently just any person can be
the good one
they just have to come trotting home
with a few tears in their eyes and some
ridiculous sob story and it's all kill
the fatted calf bring the red the ring
of family authority
put it on his finger
uh maggie my wife and i we have two boys
and they are loud and crazy and
wonderful and disobedient
and so eve my daughter um she's our
oldest and she's kind of found her
her niche in the family as
the good one uh you know she's the
oldest one the respectable one
and i remember though a few months back
one day for whatever reason
one of our boys decided to be a perfect
angel
it was i mean all day it was yes sir and
no sir and yes ma'am
i am happy to help with those dishes oh
yes
i'll certainly set the table i mean he
was just an
angel from heaven for like 12 hours
didn't last
but those 12 hours angelic and that
night
i was talking with my daughter eve
quietly in her room
and she began to cry because it was a
bit of an identity crisis for her and
these were her words
he's not the good one
i'm the good one
ah she could just pluck that right out
of luke chapter 15. i think
she just nailed it and and
what this gets my mind going is to think
what does that do
to the older child what does that do to
us
in our minds this is um what the
christian and spiritual writer henry now
and kind of reflecting on this story
this is
what he wrote he said there are many
elder sons
and elder daughters who are lost
while still at home
and i think you could argue that that's
actually the greater tragedy
then the son or daughter who runs away
you know because
everyone thinks right that the
responsible one
the performing one everyone thinks well
they're okay when sometimes you're not
okay we can be lost while still
at home so what do i mean and what does
now i mean this this kind of image of
being
lost while still at home i think it's
when we struggle
with with feelings like these the
feeling of being
um abandoned unworthy
unacceptable unloved rejected
isolated i mean you can be isolated even
while being
apart right you can feel that alone
not enough and the thing is
for many people these these feelings
drive them push them to be wildly
productive
they are achievers they're
killing it but
they often struggle with feeling empty
inside
because they're being shriven not
so much by love but by these negative
emotions and this particularly gets
pretty intense
under stress right if they think failure
or rejection is looming
then it just it kicks into overdrive as
we
we kind of hear that in the story uh now
you say brett
how on earth do you know all this
well partly from the story but um
mostly from my own life i have i do have
a little bit of son number one in me i
mean i've struggled with addiction and
such
but that's not that's not like my my
personal primary hell
uh mostly i am sun
number two um or let's say to put it
more accurately i am son
number two in recovery uh
my greatest fear is
failure i mean i worry all the time
about for example
um this church community the table
failing even though it's all very hazy
about like what exactly that would mean
um i don't really know i just i just
know i would never
want anyone to say you failed oh god
that just might be the end of my little
world
and i i also can kind of struggle
to form um kind of deep connections with
people because i don't
open up easily at all but on the other
hand at the same time i really
crave people's acceptance and approval
it's kind of a weird
mixture so all that to say i feel like
when i read now and's words
uh i know exactly what he's talking
about when he says you can be lost
while still at home and
my hunch is um many of you do
as well and even if you personally maybe
you're more son number one my hunch is
you are in relationship with someone who
is very much a son daughter
um number two so this all kind of begs
the question
um how do we come home like if you're
stuck in that place you know what
what do we do i want to kind of frame
this
as three transitions or shifts
we need to make so here are the three
shifts uh number one
we need to shift from self provision
to god or you could say others provision
um because again son daughter number
twos tend to be very
self-reliant they don't need anyone
they will do it on their freaking own
they
they don't want or need help why because
help
is weakness right that kind of makes
them look like some
um son number one and like no no that's
not me i
i am who i am because i'm not that
right and but unfortunately this
mentality
actually ends up feeding our sense of
isolation
so we have to shift remember the
father's response in verse 31
everything i have is yours
that's the shift right away from
scarcity
away from this i will pull myself up by
my bootstraps
no no you will not you you cannot you
should not
it's healthy for us to rely
on others it's healthy for
for us to pray and to ask god like
lord please provide for me sustain me
i'm in need
right learning to trust learning to
receive
help for a son daughter number two
that's incredibly
um just so healthy and i suspect my wife
maggie i bet she's dying right now she's
like brett
you're preaching to yourself tonight i
know
i know honey um so
all right number two shift number two is
we need to shift from
self protection to god slash
others protection you can hear these are
kind of similar
um because i'm sort of circling around
similar themes but i hope you can hear
their
kind of with a slightly different
emphasis so so this one's about the idea
of
safety and protection um son daughter
number twos
are low on trust
at least trusting others right they tend
to really only trust themselves
and they have trouble moving towards
others in a posture that says
i'm gonna let you in i'm gonna
trust you i'm gonna be vulnerable in a
way
that would actually leave me in a place
where you
could hurt me but i trust i trust you i
trust that you aren't going to take
advantage but rather that you're going
to
protect me and of course it's the same
with god
right god i'm learning to trust i'm
learning
to trust that you will protect and guide
me i'm
i'm learning to live vulnerably so
so this is kind of you can think of this
as like a muscle that needs to be
developed if you find yourself as a son
daughter
number two this is a muscle you need to
start working you say
well i can't do this well you you what's
the old saying you make the path by
walking it
that's kind of what i may mean is you
you just have to start stepping out but
i'm trying to give you some guidance as
to
what steps to take so so learn to trust
start start finding some people that you
can trust and begin
to actually trust them
or same with god if you find yourself
kind of not trustworthy god
like you've got to let down your god
guard you've got to learn
to trust all right third and finally
we need to shift from i'm going to call
it
self bondage to god slash
others bonding i probably won't surprise
you to hear
that son daughter number twos have
problems you know
challenges bonding with others and
here's the key insight
it's difficult to give unconditional
love to
others if you have not
first received it remember the opening
lines of the father's response the key i
think it's maybe the most beautiful
lines in the whole story
you are always with me
you're always with me what what did he
mean by
with me that's that's the language
of relationship and love
right in other words the father is
saying can't
you see that i love you
don't you no i am proud of you
don't you know i will support and care
for you
and if i want to throw a party for
someone else why does that
diminish you and and if i want to show
grace to someone else
why does that cheapen it for you you
have my love you
have my love you have
my affection i am
with you you see it's not only
on the rebels among us
who need to come home who need
to find peace it's it's all the
exhausted ones
the ones who have spent their lives
trying to earn something trying to
prove that they are worthy and to
all of you tonight i think this is god's
word
to you sh you
already have my love
can i pray for you lord jesus
i lift up every daughter and son
number two out there
and i pray that they would know that you
are always with them that they
have your love that you are proud of
them
that you're a good father a good mother
that you nurture and hold them and
sustain them and provide
for them that they don't always have to
be strong that they can learn
to be vulnerable learn to trust again
god help us help us to walk in that
help us to be that god to be that
example
and to experience it down to our toes
because i trust that when that happens
nothing will ever be the same we will be
a transformed
people do your good work
in us the powerful name of jesus i pray
amen
[Music]
you could love me as a wife
should that be
[Music]
should i read between lies
and look for blessings in disguise
to make me handsome rich and wise
[Music]
i is confess i put you
on just like a wedding dress and i
run down the aisle
i run down the aisle i'm a particle
[Music]
[Applause]
to you
so could you love this bastard child
i don't trust you to provide
one hand in a pot of gold
with the other in your side
i am so easily satisfied
[Music]
take a little cash over your
very
i am a i do confess
i put you on just like a wedding dress
and i
run down the aisle
i run down the aisle i'm a prodigal
and no way home i put you on just like a
ring of golden eye
run down the aisle
run down
[Music]
eyes
deceives his wife
i am a i do confess
i put you on just like a wedding dress
and i
run down the aisle
run down the
[Music]
the aisle i'm a prodigal
with no way home i'll put you
on just like a ring of gold and i
run down the aisle
run down the aisle to you
[Music]
uh thank you guys so much for that um
so i just want to thank everyone for
coming out tonight
um and paying attention and tuning in to
us
um i wanted just to share that
personally
i have feel very supported and loved
by this community i i can't even tell
you how much
i can pick up my phone and have a
message from somebody
from this church or connected in the
church in some way
super encouraging especially in this
moment where i can't racially see people
face to face
um it's not easy to do that and so
i'm very fortunate and i'm very blessed
all the time
when it comes to these kinds of things
and i hope that if you're ever in a
situation where you just
need some support that you can actually
um reach out um any of these people from
the table
or would be willing to sit and pray with
you to try to connect with you in some
way
so um if your needs support some prayer
um just send send us a message send a
message through facebook
um if you have a phone number of one of
the leaders
message them anything that we possibly
can our leaders will show up
they are very consistent about that
also for those of you who support the
table financially
thank you your gift is very empowering
it just carries
on the work that just allows everyone
here to
do the work they're doing and also give
to organizations like the five lowe's
pantry that's in taxi
and then just a couple of things if you
haven't had a chance to
be able to if you want to give you can
do that
if you go to the website at the table
the table tx dot com and in the top
corner there's a section that says
giving
uh you can select that and be able to
give
don't forget about the announcements i
mentioned earlier about the book club
um and also the save the table that's
happening later on in this month
and then just as we close i just want to
share uh just
this very quick uh benediction it comes
from second corinthians
um chapter 13. uh made the grace
of the lord of jesus christ and the love
of god and the fellowship of the holy
spirit i'll be with
you all be blessed and have an amazing
week
you